fewer more excited than our own jamie
wax jamie is a louisiana native he says
he's been going to jazz fest since he
was a teenager over the years he's
attended with his friends his family now
his wife and his children this morning
is sharing his love letter to this very
unique event
everyone in every place missed their
celebrations during the pandemic
but here in new orleans a city built on
over 300 years of deep celebrations some
losses went equally deep and made life
here in the big easy
a little difficult and this just in jazz
fest has announced it is canceling this
year
[Music]
i know i know big deal it's a music
festival
but jazz fest means so much more than
that here there are friends and family
we only see at jazz fest yes there have
been huge headliners like bruce
springsteen stevie wonder and the who
but my favorite jazz fest memories have
been hugging a long-lost friend under
the shade of the big oak seeing a local
church choir blow the roof off the
gospel tent watching a young mardi gras
indian proudly carrying on his family's
tradition
happy jazz fest 2022 and of course like
any louisiana celebration there's the
food food most of us only get at jazz
fest crawfish bread crawfish monica
cochon delay po boy a little fresh slaw
on there this is miss linda's yakimaine
comes from chinese immigrants and
african culture it's an incredible
combination of cultures for new orleans
i could and did go on and on
when jazz fest was canceled for the
first time since it started in 1970 and
yes that includes the year after katrina
then rescheduled then canceled again it
wasn't just devastating to those of us
in the audience
but as new orleans own tank from tank
and the bangas told us we're back
that's all i can say
[Music]
for me the experience has been truly
personal ever since my older cousin took
me to my first jazz fest in the 80s in
fact
13 years ago this week i had my fourth
date with the woman who would become my
wife at jazz fest it was the date when i
realized i wasn't just into this woman i
was falling in love with her as you can
see on my face in this embarrassing
photo from that day
[Music]
since then we've created memories there
with our older children now we get to
enjoy our pandemic babies first fest
[Music]
[Applause]
the festival's official title is the new
orleans jazz and heritage festival and
heritage might be the most important
part of it all
it honors the traditions and gifts given
to us by immigrants and enslaved people
by cooks and craftsmen it reminds us
that when we share each other's music
food and culture with open hearts we're
sharing love and respect for what makes
us different
and what makes us alike
not even disease or division can stop
that
in a complicated world at a complicated
time that seems like something worth
celebrating
[Music]
[Applause]
you know there is that song called the
look of love oh